c'est qu'il est en voiture je suis passé
à fond en marche arrière devant un radar
pas de ckoi j'ai récupéré si paul permis
direct messieurs soit c'est une émission
de ouf dans un instant recevoir
marc-antoine le bret
là antoine le bret qui va nous parler de
son nouveau spectacle je les adore c'est
mon préféré soit un autre ancien
chroniqueur de l'émission
pierre ménès quitte avec les six ans
raconte alors on me dit dans
l'oreillette que c'est bernard menez
echirey riche en douce dans un masque en
or a appelé la grand-mère de caris on
lui dira que booba et mabiala ken mais
d'abord j'ai présenté mes chroniqueurs
moi mes chroniqueurs je vous dis c'est
pas les meilleurs mais ils sont pas
chères
je le contrôle et j'ai même perdu des
fiches thiriez aulas elle ne touche pas
à l'édito elle ne touche pas aux
platines et pourtant elle arrive à
toucher un salaire qu'elles y sont le
maquereau de la merguez sur le tajine le
loukoum sur la crème brûlée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean claude van damme bonjour envoie
enchanté on se parle plus tard et
bientôt le bal des campings on va
pouvoir faire des chants bretons faisant
décollage nolwenn leroy merlin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'il est en voiture je suis passé
un fou en marche arrière devant un radar
ouais pas de ckoi j'ai récupéré six
points de permis direct jean claude tu
vas essayer 15 limitation en une minute
contre sa fin en gros si secondes pour
faire une voix et une vanne sur la
personne fait qu'il faut une voix et une
vanne je te donne je donne à chaque fois
les personnes
ok tu me dit compter près allez c'est
parti à tokyo bottines bachelot bas les
hommes c'est comme des poissons rouges
il dirige principalement avec leur qu
ils ont mis tout de ce qu'on a comme
booba hockey chose bombe a donc pas eu
l'air de carol hughes arielle dombasle
bonjour c'est arielle dombasle
soir toutes les personnes présentes
bonsoir à tous les ordres et bonsoir à
tous les hommes et à tous et toutes les
femmes vers saint françois cusey sur le
chef françois cluzet bon je suis super
content didier deschamps margeur moi et
mes dents de lait nous sommes contents
d'être athée jean marie bigard c'est
vrai que attention tout est une question
de vocabulaire comme dans la phrase la
petite île encore pris 15 cm c'est eh
ben c'est pas pareil si c'est vrai qu'il
a dit ou cissé me louis belleau agir
contre le réchauffement climatique n'est
ce pas mon cher philippe candeloro tu
m'étonnes elson est vrai qu'il ya deux
trois bonnes à ton public s donne envie
d'agir
sacré réchauffement climatique dans mon
suis par nature de l' homo mais au pq
j'exige comme je vous l'aï situe à la
muscu gilles verdez maths en l'air c'est
en automne bernard de la villardière on
tend alors qu'harry ce truc
chantal ladesou
alors j'ai trés des cheveux dans télé 3d
emmanuel macron de perdre mais vous dire
mais les décisions c'est comme les
femmes j'aime quand elles ont mûri très
longtemps et je vous dis tout ça
je vous dis tout ça sankara mais stoïque
au concret plein table sans qu'un seul
c'est moi qui parle c'est moi qui parle
mec là c'est moi qui parle latin c'est
moi c'est moi qui parle à un ok alors je
te kiffe alors françois damiens pour
finir au chômage est vraiment un coup
j'ai rien et comme vous aussi vous êtes
cool ça fait une sacrée paire de cool
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]